Guten Morgen. Polat ist mein Name. Ich bin auf diese Station als Estan 172 und würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Anandesegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Gerne Frau Polat, gerne.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich zuerst Ihre persönlichen Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie? Mein Name ist Hazel.
Hazel, ist das Nachname? Das ist mein Nachname.
Können Sie mir die Vorname nennen? Petra.
Ihr Nachname ist Ha-A-S-E.
Genau. Frau Petten, Frau Hazel. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau gebogen?
Am 1.6.1968. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 70 Kilo. Wie groß sind Sie?
1.68.
Frau Hazel, was für die Beschwerden haben Sie? Wie kann ich Ihnen heißen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr anderthalb Wochen immer wieder Fieber, Müdigkeit, Kopfschmerzen.
Meine Gelenke tun mir weh und ich habe Schmerzen am Hals.
Haben diese Beschwerden flöster begonnen oder eher langsam?
Es hat erst mit Halsschmerzen angefangen und später hat es dann Fieber gemacht bei mir,
dass Fieber kommt und geht und die Gelenkschmerzen und die Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, ist klar.
Okay. Ist das meine Ich-Fieber?
Haben Sie die Fieber gemessen?
Ja, immer über 39 Grad. 39,5, 39,6.
Es ist manchmal bei 38,5 oder sogar bei 39.
Okay. Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe Paratztamol eingenommen. Ich habe Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Es hilft ein bisschen, aber es löst mein Problem nicht.
Das Fieber kommt immer wieder.
Und die Halsschmerzen kommen auch immer wieder.
Okay. Haben diese Beschwerden im Verlauf der Zeit versteckt oder gelindert?
Ja, also die Halsschmerzen, die Kopfschmerzen werden mehr, muss man sagen.
Deswegen bin ich auch heute hier.
Mein Hausarzt wusste auch nicht weiter. Mein Hausarzt hat gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was du hast.
Sie müssen ins Krankenhaus.
Ja, wann waren Sie beim Hausarzt?
Ich war ja schon zweimal bei meinem Hausarzt.
Und er hat auch Blut abgenommen und er hat ein bisschen die Entzündungszeichnung gesehen.
Aber er hat nicht weiteres gemacht.
Ich war letzte Woche da und ich war vorgestern da.
Am Freitag war ich da.
Okay. Haben Sie bemerkt, dass es in irgendwelche oder bestimmte Auslöser gibt?
Nein.
Okay. Ich meine Kopfschmerzen.
Wo haben Sie die Kopfschmerzen?
Das ist eher linksseits bei mir hier.
Aber es kommt darauf an, manchmal ist es auch der ganze Kopf.
Aber am meisten haben Sie linksseitige Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, also normalerweise habe ich nie Kopfschmerzen.
Das ist für mich neu.
Das ist eher so ein drückender Schmerz.
Aber der geht nach, wenn ich paratstermol oder ibuprofenen Name, geht der weg.
Das ist kein Problem. Aber es kommt immer wieder.
Und mich stören diese Halsschmerzen, die ich habe.
Okay. Haben Sie Luftnot oder enge Gefüll im Brust?
Nein, gar nicht.
Aber es wird immer so warm und dann wird es manchmal wieder kalt.
Komisch, ganz komisch das Ganze.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Familie oder Ihre kontaktierende Person
endnicher beschwerden haben?
Nein, also mein Sohn hat das nicht.
Ich bin alleine gezielt und mein Sohn hat das Problem nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlucken?
Nein, ich habe ein bisschen.
Manchmal als wenn ich so ein Fremdkörper gefühlt habe,
als wenn es ein bisschen drückt am Hals.
Aber auch nur manchmal.
Ich kann normal essen, normal trinken,
aber manchmal habe ich ein bisschen drückendes Gefühl.
Ja, oder haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Fieber haben,
aber haben Sie dabei Stuhlfrost?
Das ist kein richtiger Schüttelfrost.
Es wird manchmal warm, manchmal kalt,
aber ich fühle mich krank.
Aber keine Schüttelfrost.
Leiden Sie unter nachschweiß oder kalt in schweiß?
Nein.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, ich wiege schon immer 70 kg.
Ich nehme kaum zu, kaum ab, immer gleich.
Okay, Frau Haase,
ist Ihnen Gelenkschwellung,
oder Hautverbrauchung?
Nein, aber die Gelenke tun mir weh.
Meinen Sie alle Gelenken oder Kleingelenken?
Also die Ellenbogen, die Schulter,
manchmal das Knie auch.
Also so Gliederschmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen habe ich eher.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut.
Ist Ihnen übel oder musst du Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Mich stört nur dieses Fieber, das ich habe,
um das es nicht runtergeht.
Und mein Haushaltswusstsein hat mich weiter.
Ich bin etwas besorgt.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch hier.
Normalerweise gehe ich nicht so oft zum Arzt.
Es stört mich schon sehr.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert?
Ja, Ibuprofenparastamol, das hilft.
Das hilft sehr gut.
Aber nach der Schmerzmittelgabe
hat diese Beschwerden nochmal bekommen.
Ja, die kommen immer wieder.
Seit einem Tag habe ich noch eine Schmerzmittelgabe.
Ich nehme jeden Tag Ibuprofen ein, auch Parastamol.
Aber das lindert abends, dann kann ich schlafen.
Dann ist es besser, aber wenn ich morgens wieder aufstehe,
ist das Problem wieder da.
Das Fieber geht auch runter.
Aber es löst mein Problem aktuell nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Augen oder
Nein, eigentlich gar nicht.
Mein Haushalt hat mich jetzt auch krankgeschrieben.
Ich bin jetzt seit Mittwoch, letzte Woche bin ich krankgeschrieben.
Weil das mich stört und ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren.
Das ist meine Nachbarin,
die ist kranker Schwester.
Und die sagt, ich habe mich nicht konzentriert.
Ich habe mich nicht konzentriert.
Es ist eine Erkrankte für mich,
Weil ich gesagt habe, dass ich Schlimmes habe.
Ich bin ein bisschen besorgt.
Wie ich verstanden habe,
haben diese Beschwิrte nach dem Ausstehen wiederbekommen.
Ja, auch wenn ich morgens die Ibuprofen nehme,
kann das abends wieder abgehen.
nicht unterdrücken, aber dann kommt es wieder. Wenn die Wirkung nachlässt, habe ich das Problem wieder.
Was sind die Schmerzen am stachsten? Tagstüber oder in der Nacht oder am Morgen?
Es ist unterschiedlich. Das ist eher so Wellen für mich. Das kommt und dann geht das wieder auch
mit dem Fieber. Genauso gleich. Schubweise. Es kommt und geht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Massellassen oder Stuttgarren? Nein.
Haben Sie oder schlafen Sie gut? Ja, wenn ich kein Fieber habe, ja. Aber wenn
ich Fieber habe, dann bin ich sehr unruhig. Deswegen nehme ich jetzt schon so lange.
Ich liebe profilienparts der Mole. Das ist sehr unangenehm für mich.
Was ich auch bemerkt habe, das habe ich vergessen zu sagen, dass mein Blutdruck hoch ist.
Der Haushalt, normalerweise habe ich niedrigen Blutdruck und der Haushalt, wo ich bei dem war,
der hat immer über 160 gewässten Blutdruck. Der sagt, der obere Wert ist zu hoch.
Okay, haben Sie Bauchschmerzen? Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig? Ja, wenn das Fieber hoch ist, dann muss ich mich schon setzen.
Also, nein. Okay.
Frau Haase, leiden Sie an die chronische Alkrankungen? Nein, ich habe keine
Erkrankungen. Bei mir wurde jedoch 2020 Osteoporose festgestellt.
Eine starke Osteoporose habe ich. Okay, nehmen Sie dagegen etwas ein? Ja, ich
stimme seit zwei Jahren jetzt Vitamin D und Calcium ein und ich bekomme auch jetzt
seit Kurzem, also ungefähr seit sechs Monaten, ungefähr bekomme ich Spritzen.
Spritzen für die Knochenaufbau. Das heißt XG war, der Wirkstoff ist denosumab.
Also, das ist so etwas wie Bisfosfanatis.
Dort, mein Haushalt, hat es gesagt. Das wörendlich einnehmen? Nein, das gibt mir das alle
vier Wochen. Okay.
Der sagt, das würde den Knochenaufbau helfen. Also vertrag ich auch gut.
Ich habe jetzt keine Probleme damit. Ist Ihnen irgendwelche ungewöhnliche
Frakturen aufgefallen? Ja, ich hatte Rückenschmerzen gehabt
und da ist eine Fraktur im Wirbelkörper gewesen und das konnten sich die,
der Haus hat sich erklären und dann hat der halt eine Knochen, da hat der Radiologe
gesagt, ich hätte, ich hätte zu, die Knochendichte wäre zu gering und deswegen
haben wir eine Knochendichtemessung gemacht und wir haben sogar eine
Schmutzentwicklung gemacht und dann hat der Hausarzt gesagt, ich muss das
nehmen, weil ich eine sehr starke Osteoporose habe.
Ja. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das, was damit zu tun haben kann jetzt.
Das ist, glaube ich, etwas anderes. Aber das kann relevant sein.
Okay. Deswegen muss ich fragen. Okay.
Ist es noch irgendwelche Krankheiten? Nicht, dass ich wüsste, nein, ich nehme
auch keine Medikamente sonst ein. Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Frau
Hase? Nein, nein.
Ist Ihnen irgendwie allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nicht bekannt. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Was meinen Sie mit vollständig geimpft?
Meine ich Corona Impfung. Ja, ja, ja, ich habe sogar vier Impfungen
bekommen. Oder haben Sie Kindheitsinfunk-Avenen?
Also bei meinem Hausarzt, der hat das kontrolliert beim letzten
Checkup. Das war jetzt vor einem Jahr gewesen. Da war alles in Ordnung,
hat er gesagt, ich bräuchte keine Impfungen.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen? Nein, ich habe eine
Flugangst, deswegen kann ich nicht so weit fliegen. Und ich war in
Holland gewesen mit meinem Sohn, aber das ist jetzt auch schon wieder lange her.
Frau Hase, sind Sie schon in den nächsten Jahren?
Oder haben Sie regelmäßig nicht mehr gehört?
Ich bin schon durch laut meiner V-Nerzen.
Das war wahrscheinlich früher bei mir. Also ich bin schon durch mit den
Wechseljahren. Ich habe keine Mensis mehr.
Das habe ich schon vor vier Jahren.
Vor vier Jahren, okay.
Frau Hase, rauchen Sie?
Ich? Aber ich rauche? Ja, rauchen Sie.
Ich mag keine Raucher. Stört mich sehr.
Ja, natürlich. Trinken Sie Azukohl? Nein.
Also sehr selten beim Geburtstag oder Weihnachten oder so, aber sonst
eigentlich nicht. Okay.
Nehmen Sie sonst keine Droge?
Ob ich Droge neune nehme? Ja.
Sehe ich auch so wie eine Droge eine nehme? Ja, ich weiß.
Aber das ist eine ultine Frage, die alle Patientinnen gefragt
werden. Ich stimme definitiv keine Droge ein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie welche einnehmen, aber ich stimme keine ein.
Okay, nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Ich kann nicht jetzt ein bisschen blöd die Frau haben.
Ich erziehe ein Kind, ich habe einen Sohn.
Ich muss ein Vorbild für meinen Sohn sein.
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Frau Hase, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Sekretärin. Aber Sie haben schon ein krank geschrieben.
Ich bin seit Mittwoch krank geschrieben. Normalerweise bin ich nie krank geschrieben.
Okay. Habt ihr sehr Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, immer. Die Arbeit, die ich schon jahrelang mache, macht mir auch Spaß.
Momentan geht das nicht. Wenn ich diese Fieber schübe,
bekomme das schon komisch. Und diese Halsschmerzen.
Also das finde ich schon blöd.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich habe gesagt, ich bin alleine ziehen.
Ich erziehe meinen Sohn. Der ist aber auch schon fast erwachsen.
Okay.
Er haben Sie nur eine Sohn.
Ja.
Das reicht auch.
Und Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie alleine leben.
Richtig. Ich habe mich getrennt von meinem Mann.
Können Sie regelmäßig Sport treiben?
Ich gehe regelmäßig spazieren. Also Sport.
Nein, kein richtigen Sport. Aber ich gehe regelmäßig spazieren.
Und Fahrrad fahren natürlich.
Ich war jeden Tag mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit.
Ja, super.
Ich weiß.
Leben, ihr Welt, oder?
Mein Vater ist verstorben, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Wo wann ist ihr Vater gestorben?
Krebs.
Welche Krebs erinnert ihr sich?
Bauchspeichelrüsenkrebs.
Gibt es oder hat Ihre Mutter König Eichkrankungen?
Bluthochdruck hat sie.
Ja, und sonst nimmt sie etwas gegen Cholesterin ein.
Ich glaube auch, ein Schilddrüsenmedikament nimmt sie ein.
Ich meine, Schilddrüsen über Funktion oder unter Funktion.
Das weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
Bin ich mehr unsicher.
Alles klar. Kein Problem.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Geht es dir gesund?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe keinen Kontakt.
Die ist weggelaufen vor Jahren.
Die lebt mich schon mit uns.
Alles klar.
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
Sie gucken etwas mit Verunsicht hat.
Aber ich habe nicht Schlimmes oder...
Man kann das liegen.
Aber Herr Haase, ich kann leider nicht...
Frau Haase, bitte. Ich bin eine Frau.
Frau Haase, ich verstehe Sie, aber ich kann gerade nicht genau sagen,
ich werde Sie körperlich unter Suchung ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen,
um die Diagnose festzustellen.
Deswegen müssen Sie bei uns bleiben für die weitere Untersuchung und Behandlung.
Dann kann ich genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Ich habe auch die Blutwerte von meinem Arzt dabei.
Möchten Sie die haben? Möchten Sie die sehen?
Oder nehmen Sie noch mal neue Blut ab?
Nein, ich werde nicht nur Blut abnehmen,
sondern auch Transgärnaufnahme und die andere diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Wollen Sie die Blutwerte von meinem Mann haben, von mir haben,
die mein Haushaltsgemacht hat? Möchten Sie die haben?
Seit wann haben Sie die Blut abgenommen?
Er hat am Donnerstag abgenommen und hat am Freitag gesagt,
ich soll zum Arzt ins Krankenhaus.
Deswegen bin ich hier, weil ich es zu hohe Entzündungswerte habe.
Was hatte ich Ihnen ja gesagt?
Ich werde andere Werte überprüfen.
Möchten Sie die Blutwerte nicht haben?
Ja, ich will.
Möchten Sie die sehen?
Ja, ich muss sie sehen.
Okay.
Dann gebe ich Ihnen die gleich.
Okay, sind Sie einverstanden?
Womit einverstanden?
Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Warum muss ich bei Ihnen bleiben?
Weil ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen,
dann diagnostische Massnahmen.
Aber ich kann wieder nach Hause gehen heute, weil ich muss zu meinem Sohn.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, dass Ihre Familie wichtig ist,
aber Ihre Gesundheit ist sehr wichtiger.
Ich kümmere mich, um alles zu schnell zu machen.
Bitte seien Sie ein bisschen geduldig.
Wenn ich sobald ich mehr Info habe,
werde ich Sie darüber auf den Laufenden halten.
Muss ich jetzt stationär bleiben?
Oder machen Sie untersuchen?
Ich kann heute Abend für Sie nach Hause gehen.
Eigentlich.
Ich bin sehr froh, wenn Sie nach den Ergebnissen der Labo
und für Perlisch untersuchen,
kann ich genau sagen, ob Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben müssen.
Aber jetzt sollten Sie bei uns bleiben, bis die Ergebnisse.
Haben Sie denn schon ein Verdacht, was ich haben könnte?
Ich habe mir gesagt, dass meine Beschreibung
aufgrund der Blutentzündung sein.
Blutentzündung?
Aber warum habe ich dann diese Halsschmerzen?
Und diese Fieber, wann kann das liegen?
Also mein Haushalt hat mir gesagt, ich habe keine Mandelentzündung.
Es ist nichts, was mit den Mandeln zu tun hat.
Es muss irgendwas anderes sein, sagt er.
Deswegen bin ich ja hier.
Wenn Sie mir nicht helfen können, gehe ich zum anderen Arzt.
Das kann ja nicht sein, dass ich hier.
Wenn Sie nicht wissen, was ich habe,
dann bin ich nicht gut aufgehoben hier.
Aber ich werde in Blut verschiedene
und ausführliche Werte gucken.
Nicht nur ein Stündungszeichen,
sondern auch infektiös oder andere Parameter möchte ich gucken.
Okay.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Alles klar.
Nehmen Sie im Alterszimmer einen Platz,
dann rufe ich Sie wieder auf.
Dann bin ich wieder auf.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Danke auch.
So.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Nichts, nichts.
Eine meiner Differenzien
ist, dass ich nicht mehr aufhörte.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Eine meiner Differenzialdiagnose zu diesen Beschwerden
ist Pfeifferdrysenfiba.
Das heißt, die Übertragung erfolgt häufig durch Kontaktinfektionen.
Typischerweise mit dem Schweizer durch das Küschen.
Deswegen muss ich Ihnen fragen,
ob ich hier eine Freundin habe?
Nein, ich habe keinen Partner.
Also, wenn ich merke, dann sind wir genau hier.
Da tut das weh.
Die Kollegin hat zwar nicht gefragt,
aber das tut genau hier weh.
Auf dieser Seite.
Genau da.
Haben Sie live genoten in anderen Körperregionen?
Nein.
Mein Haushalt hat gesagt, ich habe keine Lungenvergerüstung.
Ich habe keine Mandelentzündung.
Ich habe keine Ohrenentzündung.
Ich habe keine Lungenentzündung, hat er gesagt.
Aber er weiß auch nicht, was ich habe.
Er hat auch getastet hier.
Er hat gesagt, ich habe keine Schwellung.
Aber wenn man hier drauf tut, dann tut das richtig weh.
Genau hier.
Und ich habe das noch nie gehabt.
Aber haben Sie keine Gewichtsänderung?
Nein, ich habe schon gesagt, ich bin seit der Geburt meines Kindes.
Ich habe immer 70, manchmal 69, manchmal 71.
Das hat sie nichts getan.
Gar nichts.
Die Schmerzen gehen weg.
Die kommen wieder nach Ibuprofen, nach Barats Damol
und diese Fieber, diese Geländschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen.
Wie gesagt, Bluthochdruck, das kenne ich gar nicht.
Das ist auch komisch bei mir.
Ich habe manchmal auch unwohl sein.
Das ist alles ein bisschen komisch.
Ich möchte, dass Sie mir helfen.
Vielleicht besprechen Sie das mal mit Ihrem Oberarzt.
Vielleicht kann der Ihnen helfen.
Oder der kommt mich untersuchen.
Ja, mein Oberarzt werde Sie nochmal untersuchen.
Möchten Sie das vielleicht erst mit Ihrem Oberarzt besprechen, dieses Thema?
Zuerst werde ich Sie untersuchen, dann mit meinem Oberarzt in Becherche prähen, darüber.
Okay, dann machen Sie das.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Wie sind Sie denn?
Elvan bin ich.
Haben Sie Schuldkuchen, Schmerzen?
Ja, manchmal.
So ein Druckgefühl habe ich.
Aber Hausarzt gesagt, keine Pharaengetis, keine Tonzylitis.
Hat der nachgeguckt und er sagte, habe ich nicht.
Er hat auch Blut abgenommen.
Er hat gesagt, dass er irgendwelche Viren kontrolliert hat, die ich vergessen habe.
EVB, EBV, irgendwelche solche Viren hat er kontrolliert.
Und er sagte am Freitag, dass ich das nicht habe.
Er hat ja mit dem Blut abgenommen, Parandons auch gut abgenommen.
Und Freitag hat er gesagt, ich habe das nicht.
Er hat gesagt, er weiß auch nicht weiter.
Ich soll ins Krankenhaus gehen, hat er gesagt.
Keine Reisangemnese.
Wie bitte?
Nee, ich war vor fünf Monaten, war ich in Holland, dann mehr gewesen.
Wissen Sie, dass Ihr Hausarzt Ihre Schilderüsofektion überprüft hat?
Ja, hat er gemacht, hat er gesagt.
Er sagte, die wären ein bisschen erhöht.
Also ich hätte eine leichte Überfunktion haben, die er hat gesagt.
Aber das wäre jetzt nicht dramatisch, dachte er.
Er sagte, das wäre ein bisschen eine Überfunktion, aber wäre jetzt nicht so dramatisch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das, was es zu bedeuten hat.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Nervous States?
Ja, ein bisschen unruhig, Fieber, es macht mich unruhig, das Ganze.
Deswegen kann ich mich auf der Arbeit nicht konzentrieren.
Ich habe mich krankschreiben lassen deswegen.
Möchten Sie vielleicht mit dem Oberarzt sprechen?
Oder ist er heute nicht da?
Arbeitet die Oberarzt heute nicht?
Nein, mein Oberarzt arbeitet jetzt.
Aber wir gerade erst mal...
Sie diskutieren noch?
Okay, ich dann.
Wir haben ein gutes Team.
Uns ihre Beschwerden machen wir in diesem Team zusammenzusprechen.
Okay, dann stellen Sie die Fragen weiter, wenn Sie sich unsicher sind.
Okay.
Guten Tag oder guten Morgen, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen, die Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Die Patientin heißt Petra Hase.
Sie ist am 1.6.68 geboren.
Sie ist 70 kg schwer und 1,68 m groß.
Die 54-jährige Patientin stellte sich bei uns wegen seit 1,5 Wochen bestehende
und persistierende Fieber, Mütigkeit, Kopfschmerzen, Gliederschmerzen und Halsschmerzen vor.
Diese Beschwerden seien allmächtig aufgetreten und wählen für mich aufgetreten.
Die Patientin hätte auch Konzentrationstörungen und manchmal Schluckbeschwerden gehabt.
Die Fragen nach Augenproblemen oder Zusten, Düstchen wurden verneid.
Sie gab antworten, dass sie zweimal, erst letzte Woche und zweite vorgestell, beim Haus,
wegen dieser Beschwerden gewesen sei.
Ihre Hausart hätte Glut abgenommen und die Entsündungszeichen und Schilderösenfunktion
seien erhört oder hätten erhört gefunden.
Wären erhört gewesen.
Seien erhört genau.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf, wie gesagt, die Schlafstörungen oder Insomnia.
Anvorerkrankungen nannte die Patientin Osteoporose seit 2020.
Sie nehmen Vitamin D und Calcium Tabletzen und den Oxomab.
Die Voröperation und Allergie sind keine Voröperation und keine Allergie bei ihr bekannt.
Sie sind vorstandig geimpft und Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Noxanamnese ist auch unauffällig.
Die Frau Hase ist Sekretärin von Beruf, aber hat gerade einen krankgeschrieben wegen diese Konzentrationstörungen.
Sie ist eine sehende Mutter und habe einen Sohn.
Sie wohnt alleine.
Ihre Familie Anamnese ist ihr Vater an Pankreas, Kasinum, verstorben.
Ihre Mutter hat ein Arteriella-Hypercholestorelemi und eine Schilddürsen-Dysfunktion gelitten.
Sie hat auch eine Schwester, aber sie hat keinen Kontakt mehr.
Hat sie einen Partner?
Nein.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Tiroiditis aus.
Als die finanzielle Diagnostik kamen Rheumatische Artitis in Betra.
Wie können Sie mit einer Tiroiditis zusammenpassen?
Tiroiditis können mit Fiebermüdigkeit, Schmerzen, Konzentrationstörungen einhergehen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass der Haushalt erhöhte Entzündungswerte und ein erhöhtes Schilddürsenwert verzeichnet hat.
Sie mussten das kontrollieren.
Aber es ist wichtiger, als die Werte.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung?
Nicht unbedingt.
Was würden Sie mit einer Diagnostik machen?
Ich werde eine Limpknoten oder Stromer haben.
Ich werde eine Laboruntersuchung und eine Sonnografie in der Schilddürsenbereich veranlasen.
Hat der Haushalt das schon gemacht?
Manche Haushalte machen Ultraschalluntersuche.
Aber vielleicht hätte die Patientin selber gesagt, dass sie Ultraschalluntersuch bekommen hat.
Ich finde es richtig.
Ob das eine Mannlentzündung ist, hätte der Haushalt es schon gesehen.
Es ist eine Blickdiagnose.
Man hätte den Haushalt mit Antibiotikum begonnen.
Aber er hat sich gedacht, warum die Patientin ins Krankenhaus schickt.
Wie würden Sie eine Thüriditis behandeln?
Hat der Haushalt schon Medikamente aufgeschrieben?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Aber die Patientin nimmt ein Fiber.
Hat der Haushalt das auch gesagt?
Selbst Medikation.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob die von Arzt eine Medikamente aufgeschrieben hat.
Die Dosis wäre auch wichtig gewesen.
Ich kann auch fragen, ob sie 400, 600, 800,
und wie viel sie davon einnimmt.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob sie nur 2 Stück am Tag nimmt.
Das hilft ja auch oft bei einer Schilddrüsenentzündung.
Das hilft ja oft bei der NSA.
Aber anscheinend hilft das nicht.
Was würden Sie als Therapie ergeben?
Ich...
Haben Sie schon mal eine Thüriditis behandelt?
Nein, nicht.
Aber Hypertröse habe ich gesehen.
Wie kann man behandeln?
Normale Hypertröse.
Würden Sie bei der Patientin eine Thürostatik Therapie anfangen?
Nein, weil das nicht genau...
weil die Patient hat Entzündung von Schilddrösen.
Deswegen nehme ich NSAR und...
Und noch etwas.
Sie geben Cortison.
Ja, Cortison, genau.
Sie geben Hochdosis bis Cortison ein.
Das muss sie auch lange nehmen.
Mehrere Wochen muss sie das nehmen.
Sie haben auch aus der Prose Cortison festeckt,
die Sie beschwerden.
Was möchten Sie jetzt behandeln?
Die Akute beschwerden oder die aus der Prose?
Sie müssen ein Kompromiss machen.
Sie müssen abwägen.
Sollte Sie jetzt ihr Leben lang mit Fieber leben?
Sie bist zum Tod mit Fieber leben.
Was sollen Sie machen?
Sie haben recht.
Cortison verstärkt die Oszioporose.
Aber auf der anderen Seite müssen Sie jetzt helfen.
Noch gibt es nichts anderes außer Cortison.
Aber das Wichtige ist,
Sie müssen ihr sagen, dass es auch ausschleichend nehmen soll.
Wissen Sie, was ausschleichend bedeutet?
Langsam dosis denken.
Langsam reduzieren.
Wenn Sie ein Ultraschall der Schildbrüse bei der Patientin machen,
wissen Sie, was Sie sehen?
Was kann man bei der Pyrothid gut sehen?
Bei der Ultraschall erwarte ich eigentlich nichts.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Sie erwarten auf jeden Fall etwas.
Man kann oft, nicht immer,
aber man kann sehr oft auf die Stelle,
wo die Schmerzen sind, die waren hier bei der Patientin,
müssen so ein Ultraschall draufhalten.
Man kann manchmal so Echoarme Bereiche sehen.
Landkartenfirma,
wie eine Landkarte,
das zeigt, dass dort eine Entzündung ist
und dass dort ein Problem vorherrscht.
Soll ich eine Zintigraphie durchführen?
Das brauchen Sie gar nicht.
Das müssen Sie nicht machen.
Sie haben eigentlich die Diagnose schon sicher,
wenn Sie die Patientin untersuchen,
die Animesis ist wichtig
und die Ultraschall-Untersuchung ist wichtig.
Sie müssen keine Zintigraphie machen.
Zintigraphie sollten Sie nur machen, wenn Sie Knoten sehen.
Aber würde ich jetzt in dieser Situation auch nicht machen.
Sie hat eine Entzündung.
In einer akuten Phase müssen wir das aktuell nicht machen.
Aber diese Ultraschall-Untersuchung,
eine Schilddröse,
ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil der Diagnostik.
Das heißt, kann Sie nicht ambulant behandelt werden?
Sie kann formal ambulant behandelt werden.
Sie muss nicht stationär bleiben.
Es sei denn, die Blutwerte sind ja so hoch
und ihr geht so schlecht.
Oder Sie hat Herzrasen und ist instabil.
Aber das ist selten.
Man kann das auch mit IV-Kotison machen,
also intravenös.
Aber meistens reicht eine Oralentherapie
mit Prittning-Solon aus.
Was dürfen Sie der Patientin auf keinen Fall geben?
Auf keinen Fall.
Sie haben jetzt eine Hypertereose verzeichnet.
Also TSA ist bei 0,00 irgendwas.
Würden Sie der Patientin jetzt
eine Kabimazol-Kirma-Zoll geben?
Oder würden Sie nicht geben?
Nein, dürfen Sie nicht geben.
Das ist Kontraindizip.
Dürfen Sie nicht geben.
Dürfen Sie sich nicht verleiten lassen,
weil wenn die Entzündung wieder runtergeht,
werden die Schilddrösen-Werte wieder normal.
Das kann sein, als nächste Woche,
dass TSA wieder normal ist.
Das ist eine andere Frage.
Darf ich Sie nicht machen?
Wichtig ist hier NSAR und Kottison.
Das ist A und O.
Der Patient muss sich in den nächsten Wochen
beim Hausarzt vorstellen.
Das muss kontrolliert werden.
Wenn der Hausarzt keine Ultraschall-Untersuchung macht,
geht es dem Patienten, wenn es die richtige Diagnose ist,
nach 2-3 Tagen besser, wenn sie Kottison eingenommen haben.
Hochdrucks sind das Kottison.
Wie lange soll die Patientin einnehmen?
4-6 Wochen muss sie das schon einnehmen.
Das sollte schon passieren.
Aber ich denke, sie lesen sich noch mal
diese Erkrankung durch.
Das kann auch schon ab und zu auftreten.
Bei Frauen ist oft eine Schilddrösen-Entzündung.
Wenn sie die Patientin eines fragen sollen,
ob sie vor dieser Erkrankung
einen grippalen Infekt gehabt hat.
Oder eine Atemwegsinfektion gehabt hat.
Man oft tritt das nach einer viralen Infektion auf.
Man weiß nicht, warum man das hat.
Aber wenn sie die Patientin vielleicht gefragt hätten,
ob sie vor 2-3 Wochen eine Entzündung gehabt hat
oder einen Atemwegsinfekt.
Vielleicht hätte die Patientin gesagt,
ja, ich habe eine grippale Infektion gehabt.
Oder ich habe eine Covid-Infektion gehabt.
Das hätten sie vielleicht noch fragen sollen.
Verstanden.
Aber ich, wie ich gewusst habe,
die Thrioditis kann man nicht auf den Hals der Reichanfassung
wegen Schmerzen.
Ja, die Patientin hat ja auch gesagt,
dass sie hier Halsschmerzen hat die ganze Zeit.
Aber sie hat nicht gefragt, ob sie überall ist.
Oder ob sie nur einseitig ist oder zweiseitig ist.
Das hat die Patientin selber gesagt.
Und wenn sie hier draufdrücken,
dann haben die immer ein Geschmerzen.
Selten, dass sie keine Schmerzen haben.
Aber meistens ist es mit Halsschmerzen verbunden,
weil dort die Entzündung ist.
Müssen sie fragen.
Wenn sie draufdrücken, ob sie Schmerzen hat,
oder müssen sie selber mit dem Finger palpieren.
Dann merken sie das schon.
Das ist dann eigentlich beweisen,
dass es eine Schilddrösenentzündung ist.
Interessant.
Ich dachte, Rheuma am meisten
kann sein, aber nach dem Angabe der Patientin
vorherige Ergebnisse am meisten Schilddrösenwerte.
Dann habe ich Schilddröde.
Wie kommen Sie auf Rheuma,
wenn sie Patienten hier Schmerzen hat?
Ich habe vorher nicht gefragt,
wo die Halsschmerzen am Stärk sind.
Sie müssen immer genau fragen.
Sie haben gefragt, wo die Kopfschmerzen sind.
Aber Sie haben nicht gefragt,
ob die Einseitig sind,
ob die Beizeitig sind.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage, die Sie stellen müssen.